[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den heute
-nachrichten ausnahmezustand in halle an
der saale in sachsen anhalt zwei
menschen wurden in der nähe der synagoge
erschossen zunächst hieß es zwei täter
seien mit einem auto auf der flucht
inzwischen wurde eine person
festgenommen
die synagoge in der innenstadt von halle
war zum zeitpunkt der tat voll besetzt
nach den schüssen sperrte die polizei
das angrenzende stadtviertel weiträumig
ab die anwohner von halle wurden
aufgefordert in ihren wohnungen zu
bleiben die stadtverwaltung spricht von
einer amok lage
schüsse auf offener straße mitten im
paulusviertel in halle ein anwohner film
wer sich ein täter seinen weg frei
schiesst mit einer großkalibrigen waffe
kurz darauf ist die polizei am tatort
ein augenzeuge erlebt alles aus nächster
nähe mit der schulter geschossen und
dann hat er wahrscheinlich klingt ja
also das mädchen das kostbare schreiben
tag begleitet und politisch ein totaler
kamphaus wirst du mit hellem display
also komplett bewaffnet wozu die
maschine war und dadurch mehrere molotow
cocktails oder verladen oder
friedhofsmauer
sie haben auch explosionen gehört genau
offenbar haben der oder die täter
erfolglos versucht in die synagoge zu
gelangen
die ist voll besetzt am höchsten
jüdischen feiertag jom kippur also
richtig sei richtig
das habe ich schon mitgekriegt ich
wollte straße hier und muss sich
ausgebrannt deckung gehen dass wir
wildwest zwei menschen werden getötet
die polizei ruft anwohner auf in den
häusern zu bleiben
nach dem angriff trennt sich die täter
offenbar und flüchten einer cup hat ein
taxi und wird kurz darauf festgenommen
auch im 15 kilometer entfernten
landsberg sollen schüsse gefallen sein
die polizei hat das nicht bestätigt ein
spezialeinsatzkommando ist dort im
einsatz
die fahndung läuft wie viele täter noch
auf der flucht sind ist unklar
die bundesanwaltschaft hat inzwischen
die ermittlungen übernommen es gebe
anhaltspunkte für einen
rechtsextremistischen hintergrund wie
hier in dresden sind bundesweit die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen an synagogen
mit worden annegret oster ist in halle
annegret es sollen weiterhin täter auf
der flucht sein wie ist in diesem
augenblick denn die situation
tatsächlich ist sie weiterhin sehr
unübersichtlich auch die polizei gibt
keinerlei auskünfte
sie sagte mir dennoch in einem kurzen
hintergrundgespräch vor der vor der
kamera äußert sich im moment keiner
es könnte sein das ist nur ein täter ist
aber auch das ist mit fragezeichen ist
es auch mit fragezeichen doch der eine
verdächtige der festgenommen wurde von
der polizei das ist bestätigt der täter
ist
dafür spricht auch dass es eigentlich
immer noch eine von einer gefährdung
auszugehen ist die polizei ruft
weiterhin die anwohner auf die häuser
nicht zu verlassen das polizeiaufgebot
aber auch das aufgebot von
rettungskräften hier ist enorm die
polizei geht von zwei tatorten aus dass
es so weit bestätigt die synagoge und
auch der kiosk ekiosk sehr in der nähe
der synagoge wo ein mann erschossen
wurde
ferner gehört der generalbundesanwalt
hat die ermittlungen an sich gezogen
warum der generalbundesanwalt geht von
einer staatsgefährdenden tat oder von
einer tat mit staatsgefährdenden
charakter aus die umstände machen das
tatsächlich naheliegend es ist eine
besondere bedeutung der tat sagt er
es spricht dafür dass es einen
politischen
terroristischen möglicherweise
hintergrund gibt die täter sollen so
berichten augenzeugen in einer
speziellen kampfmontur aufgetreten seien
der oder die täter
da sind sich die augenzeugen auch nicht
einig es gibt zwei tote zwei morde und
möglicherweise steht die tat auch im
zusammenhang mit yom kippur das ist das
höchste jüdische feste feiertag der
heute begangen wird auch deswegen waren
in der synagoge 70 bis 80 menschen dort
und damit voll besetzt der täter hat
wohl versucht die synagoge zu stürmen
aber das ist nicht offiziell bestätigt
vielen dank für diese information
annegret oster inhalten die schüsse in
halle die fahndung nach den tätern die
warnungen der polizei alle entwicklungen
erfahren sie sofort in unserem live blog
auf heute.de in halle herrscht angst nur
40 kilometer entfernt dagegen soll heute
gefeiert werden 30 jahre friedliche
revolution in leipzig wird heute an den
neunten oktober 1989 erinnert damals
gingen in der stadt 70 tausend menschen
gegen das sed regime auf die straße
einen monat später fiel die mauer die
ddr war geschichte heute 30 jahre danach
bei der gedenkfeier auch
nachdenklichkeit christoph schmidt hat
diesen gedenktag jahrelang gemieden
er hat sich nicht einmal in die nähe
leipzig gewagt denn hier erlitt er vor
30 jahren am 19 oktober ein schweres
trauma er stand damals zufällig in der
ersten reihe der demonstranten in der
gewissheit dass heute wohl geschossen
werden würde das gefühl 70.000 leute
schieben von hinten und direkt vor mir
steht eine schützenkette mit einer waffe
die ich kannte das hat in mir ein angst
trauma ausgelöst was ich leider wirklich
bis heute mit mir rumschleppen
aber heute will er seine geschichte
erzählen
auch renate weise ist zum zeugen bus
gekommen
sie meint dass langsam in vergessenheit
geraten dass die mutigen menschen damals
in bewegung gebracht haben
das wäre ganz wichtig dass vor allen
dingen uns die in den neuen
bundesländern mehr zugehört wird weil
wir unsere geschichte wurde teilweise
auch vergessen bundespräsident
steinmeier bezeichnet diesen neunter
oktober als großen tag der deutschen
geschichte
doch bei aller feierlichkeit auch viel
nachdenken
ich sehe ein land in dem sich risse auf
thun risse die sich auch in
wahlergebnissen wider spiegeln aber mehr
noch in der art und weise wie wir
übereinander und wie wir über dieses
land reden
70.000 gingen heute vor 30 jahren gegen
das sed regime auf die straße diese
demonstration war wohl der sargnagel für
die ddr nur vier wochen später fiel die
mauer
ausgangs- und mittelpunkt der
demonstrationen war immer die
nikolaikirche
großer andrang in diesen minuten findet
ihr traditionellen friedensgebet statt
die türkei hat ihre militäroffensive im
nordosten syriens begonnen das hat
präsident erdogan mitgeteilt unmittelbar
nach der erklärung flog die türkische
luftwaffe erste angriffe auf syrisches
gebiet mit dem einsatz will die türkei
die kurden milizen aus der grenzregion
vertreiben die noch bis vor kurzem an
der seite der amerikaner gegen den as
gekämpft hatten
ziel der türken ist dort eine 30
kilometer breite sogenannte
sicherheitszone zu errichten um syrische
flüchtlinge aus der türkei dorthin
abzuschieben
thomas gilt in istanbul wie sieht denn
diese offensive genau aus was ist bisher
bekannt
also um 16 uhr ortszeit hat ja diese
operation der türkischen armee begonnen
es gibt erste luftschläge östlich des
rats und mittlerweile eben auch
artilleriebeschuss der türken
bodentruppen konnten können wir hier
noch nicht besteht bestätigen erdogan
plant ja wie gerade gesagt eine
schutzzone von 30 kilometern im
landesinneren als puffer zu diesen
bewaffneten kurden und da ist ganz
entscheidend wie weit diese pufferzone
wie weit er darin
land eingreifen will davon ist abhängig
wie groß diese türkische offensive dann
wird spannend ist auch da wird man noch
nicht so viel von von den kurdischen
milizen wie die reagieren die haben nur
gesagt dass sie auf jeden fall sich
verteidigen werden und das problem ist
die die zivilbevölkerung hier auf
syrischer seite leben und mehrere
hunderttausend menschen nicht nur kunden
sondern eben auch araber und man kann
davon ausgehen dass wenn es jetzt hier
zu den kämpfen kommen wird dass dann
eine neue flüchtlingswelle droht
vielen dank für die information thomas
gill in istanbul der klimaschutz soll in
deutschland gesetzt werden den
entsprechenden entwurf zum klimaschutz
paket hat die bundesregierung auf den
weg gebracht darin werden konkrete ziele
im kampf gegen den klimawandel bis zum
jahr 2030 festgelegt so sollen zb
gegenüber 1990 die
treibhausgasemissionen um mindestens 55
prozent sinken
als langfristiges ziel verfolgt die
bundesregierung bis 2050
klimaneutralität opposition und
umweltverbänden geht das gesetz nicht
weit genug
keine frage wer ausfliegen verzichtet
wer sein diesel oder benziner in der
garage stehen lässt und auf die bahn
umsteigt tut etwas für den klimaschutz
daher ein wichtiger punkt im klimapaket
fliegen soll teurer werden die
mehrwertsteuer für zugtickets dagegen
sinken
mehr menschen sollen also mit der bahn
fahren doch vorher muss die weichen
stellwerke bahnhöfe sanieren eine
herkulesaufgabe
die bahn als klimaretter doppelt so
viele fahrgäste soll sie in zehn jahren
transportieren
doch das verstopfte schienennetz kann an
knotenpunkten schon jetzt keinen zusatz
verkehr verkraften muss in einer
beispiellosen anstrengung erst fit für
die hohen erwartungen gemacht werden wie
ein bündel von maßnahmen digitalisierung
entkrampfung der knoten ausbau der
strecken und bessere stabilität im
vorhandenen system wollen wir bis zu
einem drittel mehr kapazität in
deutschland gewinnen es wird ein
jahrzehnt der bahn baustellen denn über
jahre vernachlässigt muss parallel zum
streckenausbau auch ein gewaltiger
investitionsstau bewältigt werden
der plan nicht nur sanieren sondern
gleich digitalisieren auf bahnverkehr
ohne signale umstellen
damit könnten bis zu 30 prozent mehr
züge auf demselben gleis fahren sagt der
bahnvorstand diese hoffnung sehe ich als
stark überhöht an digitalisierung ist
zwingend notwendig aber es muss auch die
hardware dazu da sein digitalisierung
ist nur ein werkzeug man kann etwas mehr
kapazität unterbringen
immerhin für den netzausbau hat der bund
im klimapaket deutlich mehr geld als
bisher bewilligt insgesamt steht bis
2030 die rekord summe von 156 milliarden
euro bereit
zu wenig kritisierten heute die
verkehrsminister der länder
das reiche nicht um auto oder flugzeug
konkurrenz zu machen und noch etwas
könnte den ausbau bremsen die bahn
braucht jetzt über 900 zusätzliche
planer techniker und ingenieure
wo die herkommen sollen ist unklar
nach der geplatzten pkw-maut gerät
verkehrsminister scheuer weiter unter
druck jetzt musste sein ministerium auf
druck der grünen weitere geheimtreffen
des ministers mit vertretern zweier
mautbetreiber firmen zu geben
der bundestag sollen die treffen trotz
nachfragen der abgeordneten verschwiegen
worden sein das verkehrsministerium
bestreitet das deutschlands
wettbewerbsfähigkeit hat im vergleich zu
anderen ländern nachgelassen in der
neuen rangliste des
weltwirtschaftsforums fällt die
bundesrepublik von platz drei auf platz
sieben zurück überholt für deutschland
von hongkong den niederlanden der
schweiz und japan frank bethmann an der
börse
warum fällt deutschland zurück was läuft
bei den anderen besser naja wenig
überraschend die bekommen das vor allem
mit dem schnellen internet besser hin
und das ist natürlich für eine moderne
gesellschaft und für eine
zukunftsorientierte wirtschaft enorm
wichtig aber bei internetverbindungen
über glasfaser und bei mobilen
breitbandanschlüssen verpasst
deutschland eine bessere platzierung
werden die bundesrepublik also bei der
informationstechnologie beim schnellen
internet lahm der zählt das land laut
der neuen rangliste in anderen
wettbewerbsrelevanten kategorien wie der
innovationsfähigkeit der inflationsrate
und bei der verschuldung topnoten das
zurückfallen im ranking muss also etwas
relativiert werden auf den vorderen ring
geht es ganz eng zu umso ärgerlicher ist
es dass ein noch besseres abschneiden
eben durch jenes nur spärlich vorhandene
schnelle internet verspielt wird ein
defizit das bereits seit jahren
existiert und wo deutschland
mittlerweile auf das niveau von
schwellenländern abgerutscht ist
vielen dank frank bethmann in franken
wieder schlechte nachrichten für kunden
von thomas cook deutschland alle reisen
bis einschließlich silvester werden
gestrichen
dies gelte auch für solche die bereits
ganz oder teilweise bezahlt wurden
teilte das unternehmen in oberursel mit
auch betroffen sind kunden von
neckermann öger tours bucher reisen und
air marin
sie sollen so schnell wie möglich
informiert werden der chemie nobelpreis
geht in diesem jahr an die väter der
lithium ionen batterie ohne die handys
laptops und elektrofahrzeuge gar nicht
möglich wären die königlich schwedische
akademie der wissenschaften verliehen
ihn an den in jena geborenen amerikaner
john gurdon auf den briten stanley
whiting hemmen und akira hoshino aus
japan
die batterien hätten unser leben
revolutioniert sie machten den weg frei
für eine gesellschaft ohne fossile
brennstoffe so die begründung
und wir kommen noch zum wetter die
aussichten für die nächsten tage in der
nacht in der mitte regen an den küsten
schauer bei teils starkem südwestwind
abkühlung auf fünf bis zehn grad morgen
im süden und im nordwesten schauer und
gewitter lebhafter südwestwind
höchsttemperatur 11 bis 17 grad am
wochenende im norden schauer und starker
bis stürmischer wind im süden viel sonne
am sonntag bis 26 grad
zur entwicklung in halle sehen sie ein
zdf spezial gleich im anschluss an die
19 uhr nachrichten mit barbara hahlweg
hier geht es weiter mit hallo
deutschland ihnen noch einen schönen tag
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]